you were like i don't see a double chin
what are you talking about
and that's the whole point that you see
yourself through this hypercritical lens
but no one else sees it so why are we
doing it
welcome back okay we are just coming out
of a video um from none other than one
of my personal heroes katie storino she
put this video on her instagram feed i
reposted it it's one of the highest
rated videos i've ever put out on my
feed she is also the founder of the
incredible beauty brown mega babe which
we're going to talk to her about and she
has this incredible book she also has
this amazing thing that she does on her
instagram as well where she takes iconic
looks that are trending right now
currently and then does a thing where
she calls super size the look we're
gonna show you a few examples but please
welcome again my personal hero katie
serena right here
in the leopard
[Music]
katie
what gave you the idea for this really
cool clear crisp concept that you have
of super sized look on instagram
well when i started my platform i
realized like very quickly that you have
to come up with outfits every single day
which is actually quite hard yeah right
so i started looking at celebrities for
inspiration and what i was finding is i
was telling people i got this idea from
reese witherspoon i put the outfit
together what do you guys think and
they're like we love reese's style but
we actually don't think that we can wear
it because of our body size so i started
to show people that you can actually you
don't have to be a size zero to wear the
things that inspire you you can actually
just wear it right now look i'm a size
18. here's a celebrity who's a size zero
right next to each other both pulling
off the look and it's never about who
wore it better because i hate that whole
concept and that mindset really keeps us
down yeah but i i love that because
people so many people don't even try a
look because they think i could never do
that and you're showing people you can
do whatever you want yeah it's about
owning whatever you do yes i'm in a full
leopard suit i'm a size 20. like this is
this is an absolute like no i've heard
this my entire life like don't wear
prints don't draw attention hide in
black it's it's it's all a lie how do
you get there are you born with that
innately is it therapy do i need to call
someone what do you do you read my book
yeah
well you wrote the book but how did you
get there um here here is here's really
what happened i started my platform to
help women who are above a size 12 get
dressed i was like oh you can buy this
code in the men's department like these
shoes might fit you from here
but what i found is that i was getting
messages from women of all sizes
especially women who were smaller than
me saying i i hate my body you're really
helping me find confidence and i was
like wait hold on you hate your body
you're a size four i'm i have been
taught my entire life that that's what i
should be striving for and you're in
this body and you're unhappy what's the
point
what is the point what are we doing here
so then that's when i started to explore
that concept and i really was like uh
why are we wasting time on this what is
who who are we really impressing like
what
why are we doing this as women um and i
i realized and i actually i was going
through a really hard time in my life
and i had put on a lot of weight and
it's during the time where i was my
heaviest that i really started to accept
myself because i realized that it wasn't
at all about the size in my dress it was
really about how i felt about myself and
how i presented and the energy i was
putting out there
[Applause]
um okay so is it true that you founded
mega babe in your parents basement
because now this is a huge brand garage
okay yes i pulled those two out of
retirement and i was like mom and dad
i'm gonna start a business um our first
product is going to be for thigh chafe
and they were like what's that
thigh chase yes yes yeah which is when
your legs rub together and and you have
a hard time walking but um really after
starting my platform i talk to i talk to
people every spring every summer and i
was like it's side chaff season what are
we doing how are we handling this and
year after year i was like there's
nothing in the market except for these
weird products for men like this is what
i'm doing i'm pulling i'm pulling this
stick out of my fancy bag and so then um
i decided to start the business and my
parents did fulfill every single order
for the first two years including when
we started selling in like big retailers
they had like a semi truck back up into
the garage
no one's forgiven me for it everyone's
still mad about it
this is my favorite product
yes i love this one what a tush mask
it's yes so we made so it's mega babe
essentially like tackles all the taboo
issues that we all deal with like thigh
chafe boob sweat butt acne but no one
talks about and we all think we're the
only ones who have it but actually we
all have it and the butt dust bust us
yes um i swear i just think that also
brands need a true angle and identity
and you totally knocked it out of the
park with this one all right now
one of the things that i love about the
super size the look program that you do
on your instagram is it does show how we
can all get that look and i would love
right now with two audience members who
are rocking outfits inspired by
jamie chung right here
and then also priyanka chopra and it's
deandra and jewel i would love for you
to come out come on out
[Applause]
so essentially zebra pants they would
say don't wear it it's not flattering
but we've got it we've got it paired
here with a sneaker and then also a pop
of red the glasses are full attitude i
love this look it's easy and depending
on your job you could definitely wear
this to work and jewel is wearing a
priyanka chopra outfit and
this is funny because you probably have
all of these elements in your closet
already and we've put them together in a
really good way that is pulled together
um but
the idea of wearing like a high boot
under jeans is something people are like
i can't wear that but yes you can
absolutely wear that um and then a camel
coat is some is something that everyone
should own in their closet
they're available in a variety of price
points and then the white turtleneck is
classic you definitely have that paired
together with the camel you look very
chic so
yeah yeah and even if it may be out of
your comfort zone but would either of
you wear this look again
yes i definitely would wear this again
it's like you said i had all of these
pieces but when i do it it doesn't look
like this
so it's great to have this example like
to super size the style it's great yes
i love that
so i am so excited because everyone is
gonna go home with a hundred dollar gift
card from mega man
[Applause]
and we can all do what we're already
doing and jewel you look so beautiful
thank you for showing us how it's done
gorgeous and katie storino i love you so
much
[Music]
you